how complicated are these little
organisms what what are we talking about
it depends on how you Define
complication
okay so I I could tell that you uh
appreciate and respect the full
complexity of even the most seemingly uh
primitive organisms because none of them
are primitive okay that said what what
kind of what what are we talking about
how how
um
what kind of machineries do they have
that you're working with when you're
injecting them with DNA so I will start
with one of the most fascinating
machineries that we target which is the
translation machinery
it is on a very unique
subsystem of cellular life in comparison
to I would say metabolism
and we used to
um you know when we are thinking about
cellular life we think of cell as the
basic units or the building block but
from a key perspective that's uh not the
case that one may argue that everything
that happens inside the cell serves the
translation and the translation
Machinery there is a nice paper that
called this that entire cell is
hopelessly addicted to this main
informatic
Computing biological chemical system
that it is operating at the heart of the
cell which is the translation it is the
translation it's translating from what
to what so RNA to enzymes it converts a
linear sequence of mRNA into a folded
later folded protein that's that's when
the uh that's the core processing center
for information for life it's uh has
multiple steps it initiates it elongates
its terminates and it recycles
it operates uh
discrete bits of information it's itself
is like a chemical decoding device and
that is incredibly unique for
translation that I don't think you will
find anywhere else in the cell that does
this so even though it's called
translation it's really like a factory
that reads the schematic
and builds a three-dimensional object
it's like a printer I would divide it
into actually even four more additional
steps or disciplines than what would it
take to study it by the way you
described it it's a chemical system it's
the compounds that make it up are
chemicals it's physical it's uh tracks
the energy to make its job to do its job
its own informatic what is processed are
the bits it's computational the discrete
states that the system is placed when
the information is being processed
that's itself is computational and it's
biological it's a there's variability
and inheritance that come from imperfect
replication even and infer imperfect
computation so you're and that's so good
so from the biology comes the like when
you mess up
the bugs are the features that's the
biology informatics is obvious in the
RNA that's a set of information there
the different steps along the way is
actually kind of what the computer does
with with bits its own computation
physical there's a uh I guess the the
like almost like a mechanical process to
the whole thing that requires energy and
actually you know it's manipulating
actual physical objects
and uh chemicals because you're
have to ultimately it's all chemistry
yeah and
so it is almost a mini computer device
inside ourselves yeah and that's the
oldest uh computational device of life
it's it's uh likely the key uh operation
system that had to evolve for life to
emerge it's uh more interesting
or it's more complicated in interesting
ways than the computers we have today I
mean everything you said which is really
really nice I mean I guess our computers
have the informatic and they have the
computational but they don't have the
chemical the physical or the biology
exactly and and the computers don't have
don't link information to function
right they are not tightly coupled
nowhere close to what translation or the
way translation does it so that's the
number one I think difference between
the two
and um yes it's it's informatic and we
can um uh discuss this further to 100
let's please discuss this further which
part are we discussing for each one of
those are fascinating worlds each each
of the five yeah so about we can start
with the more I guess the the ones that
are more established which is the the
chemical aspect of the translation
Machinery it's uh the specific compounds
make up the Assembly of RNA chemists
showed this in many different ways we
can rip apart the entire Machinery we
know that at the core of it there's an
RNA that's
um
that operates not only as an information
information system itself or information
itself but also as an enzyme and and
origin of Life chemists make these
molecules easily now we know we can
manipulate RNA we can make even with
single part chemistries we can create
compounds what's a single part chemistry
um that's I would say when you add all
the recipes that you know that will lead
you to the final products do is they
they come up with this pod they throw a
bunch of chemicals in and they try to
try to they're basically Chefs of a
certain kind I'm not sure if that's what
they call it but that's how I think of
it because it is all combined in a test
tube and you know the outcome and and
it's it's mathematical once you know the
right environment and the right
chemistry that needs to get into this
container or the spot you know what the
outcome is there's no luck there anymore
it's a pretty rigid established uh input
output system and it's all chemistry so
you actually wear a lot of hats as one
of them original life chemist my PhD is
in chemistry but I don't do original
live chemistry but you're interested in
origin of Life yes absolutely for some
of your some of your best friends the
original life chemists just make sure
that you have good chemist friends if
you're interested in origin of Life yeah
that's a hundred percent requirement
should be mandatory okay so chemistry uh
so what else about this Machinery that
we need to know chemically well uh
chemically I think that that's it you
have enzymes you have proteins the
enzymes are doing their thing they know
how to chew energy using ATP or GTP they
they know what to do on their in their
own way they do their enzymatic thing so
it's not just the ribosome that is at
the heart of the transition but there
are a lot of different proteins you're
looking about a hundred different
components that compose this Machinery
uh well let me ask kind of maybe it's a
ridiculous question but did the
chemistry
make this machine or did the machine
use chemistry to achieve a purpose
so like
um
I guess there's a lot of different
chemical possibilities on Earth
is is this much translation Machinery
just like uh choosing picking and
choosing different
chemical reactions that you can use to
achieve a purpose
uh or did the chemistry basically
like uh there's like a momentum like a
constraint to the thing that can only
build a certain kind of Machinery that's
basically is is chemistry fundamental or
is is it just emergent like how
important is chemistry to this whole
process you cannot have
life without chemistry you cannot have
tiny
process without
chemistry what makes life interesting is
that even if the chemistry isn't perfect
even if there are accidents along the
way if something binds to another
chemical in in a way it shouldn't
um there is resilience within the system
that it can maybe not necessarily repair
itself but it moves on have everything
perfect
mistakes can be handled that's where the
biology that's where the biology comes
in but in terms of chemistry you
absolutely cannot have a transition
missionary without chemistry and so
you're as I said there are four main
steps these are the core steps that are
conserved in all translation missionary
and I should say all life has this
machine right
every cell everything on Earth on Earth
yeah yes when you think of this machine
do you think very specifically about the
kind of Machinery that we're talking
about or do you think more
philosophically the machine that
converts information into function it's
I it's I cannot separate the
Machinery fascinating
those five components that I listed are
they coexist
so for instance if we uh let's just
talking about the chemistry Parts
um we we know the certain
um rate constant all these proteins that
operate in this Machinery needs to
Harbor in order to get the mechanism
going
right if you are bringing the the
information to the translation machinery
and you're the initiator of this
computation system you need to have uh
you can only afford a certain range of
mistakes if you're too fast then the
next message cannot be delivered fast if
you're too slow then you may stall the
process so there is definitely a
chemistry constant going on within the
Machinery
um again it's not perfect far from it
but they all have their own margin of
error that they can tolerate versus they
cannot otherwise they collapse the
system collapses so it's like a Jazz
Ensemble the notes of the chemistry but
you can be like that you said Jazz it's
definitely true it's a party and it's
like everybody's invited and and and
they need to operate together right and
and they um what's really cool about it
I think or there are many things that
are very interesting about this thing
but if you take if you remove it from
the cell and put it in a Cell free
environment it works just fine right so
you can get cell free translation
systems uh put this transition in a test
tube and it is
doing its thing it doesn't need the rest
of the cell to translate information of
course you need to feed the information
at least so far
um but because we are far from evolving
a transition maybe not so far uh
evolving a translation in the lab or the
Machinery that can process information
as it generates it we have not done that
yet it's a pretty complicated Machinery
so it's hard for it to for those uh
origin of Life chemists to find a part
that generates because it's far more
than chemistry you need you need uh
biology obviously you need biochemistry
you need to think as a I think a network
systems folk you need to think about
computation you think about information
and and that is not happening yet except
we are trying to bring this perspective
but the more you understand uh how the
information systems work you cannot once
you see it you cannot unsee it it's one
of those things so but you can still rip
it out and the chemistry happens yes and
chemistry can happen even with even if
you strip some of the parts out it can
you can get very minimal level of
information processing that does not
look anything like the translation that
cells relies on but that but chemists
showed from linear you can generate
information that arrives to a processing
center in the form of a linear polymer
the informatic part of this system that
I think sets it apart from computation
and from metabolism comes in if you
think about the information itself right
so we have four nucleotide letters that
compose DNA and um they are processed in
the translation in triplets
so you have in in triplet codon
fragments so you have four times four
times four so you have 64 possible
states that can be encoded
by four letters in three positions
all right so it's so amazing yeah it's
so amazing there is only one code that
says start that's that there's only one
and then there's two if not three that
says stop
so that's that's that's what you work
with but you can have 64 possible States
but life only uses 20. amino acids so we
used six live users 64 possible States
minus four of the starts and stops to
code for 20 amino acids in different
combinations
that is really amazing if you think
about there there are 500 different
amino acids life can choose right
narrowed it down to training we don't
know why a lot of people think about
this genetic code is quite fascinating
right I mean it didn't do it for four
billion years I don't know we may wait
for another four billion years but but
you didn't have those amino acids in the
very beginning right like you don't know
so it we would be fooling ourselves if
we said we know exactly how many amino
acids existed early on but there's no
reason to think that it's it wasn't the
same similar yeah we don't we don't have
a good reason but
but because roughly 20 out of 60 states
are used you're using one-third of your
possible states in the in your
information system so it this may seem
like a waste but informatically it's
important because it's abundant and it
is
um redundant right so so this code
degeneracy you see this in that's
implemented by this translation
missionary inside the cell
so it means we can make errors right you
can make errors but the message will
still get through you you can speak
missing some letters to the information
can miss some parts but the message will
still get through so that's two-thirds
of the not used States give gives you
that robustness and resilience within
this system so at the informatic level
there's room for error there's probably
room for probably in all five
uh categories we're talking about
there's probably room for air in the
computation that's probably from yes
exactly everywhere yeah because because
the this informatic capacity is made
possible together with the other
um components and not only that but also
the the product yields
a function no
in this case enzyme are pretty right so
so
that's really amazing for me it is I
mean I mean in my head just so you know
because I'm a computer science AI person
the the parallels between even like
language models that encode language
or now they're able to encode basically
any kind of thing including
um images and actions all in this kind
of way
the the parallel in in terms of
informatic and uh computation
is just incredible